One definition of NP says, that a problem is in NP, if it has a short accepting certificate.
An accepting certificate is information that we can use to quickly show
that the answer to the decision problem is yes, (if it actually is yes)
and here, short means polynomial size and quickly means polynomial time.
To define NP even more formally, we're going to say a problem is an NP
if there is a verification in algorithm.
This is a basically computer program on A like a subroutine A
such that for any input for the problem that is a "yes", there is a certificate C
such that the size of C is polynomial in the size of x, and the verification algorithm will say "yes"
but for any x that is a no, there is no certificate C that's polynomially sized with respect to x
and the verification algorithm says "yes", so for any yes answer to the problem,
a verification algorithm will say "yes" for some small certificate;
otherwise, it'll say "no" for all small certificates.
For the Sudoku example, the verification algorithm is what we describe
as something to take the original Sudoku problem with things not filled in
and the answer is printed in the back of the magazine where the answer filled in,
and it checks to see whether this is the actually a solution to that.
If it is, then it says "yes" and if it's not, it says "no".
Now this is going to fit the NP definition that we've got here
because for any Sudoku problem that is solvable, there is some grid that we solve it and we can show
what that grid looks like, but for any problem that it's not solvable,
there is no way that we can fill in this grid with numbers.
So that the verification algorithm will say that it's okay.
It really is back to the definition of basically the Sudoku problem.
The Sudoku problem says, "Is there a way of filling it in?"
And the certificate that we use is, well, we'll show you how it's filled in.
It fits both half of this definition, so this problem is an NP.
Now let's be a little careful here because Sudoku as it's typically designed,
doesn't really have an input size; all the inputs are of the same size.
but you can imagine a generalization of Sudoku where you have a bigger grid
and maybe more symbols and the same kind of verification procedure works.
The bigger the grid gets, the longer it takes to run,
but it's always a polynomial in the size of the input grid.
Let's try to put this definition to work and answer the following question:
Is P contained within or possibly equal to NP?
So one possibility here is, I don't know, and if I knew that, I'd win a Fields Metal!,
meaning sort of the equivalent of the Math Nobel Prize
because this is a big important open question.
The other choice is no, P is not contained within NP because if the problem is NP,
it means it's decidable in polynomial time and we don't need any kind of certificate
and so, it's not an NP and then finally the opposite of that is,
yes if it can be decided in polynomial time, no certificate is needed.
So if you have a problem that's NP, then you don't need any sort of certificate, so it's also in NP.